hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar new fixable viability dies and
applications for flow cytometry i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by thermo
fisher scientific to learn more visit
them at thermofisher.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have during this presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
now this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits
we will announce our two winners of the
t-shirt contest toward the end of the
webinar so please stay tuned
i'd now like to welcome our speaker
chris langsdorff a staff scientific
scientist at thermo fisher scientific
chris welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
hi thank you for joining us today my
name is chris langsdorff and i'm a staff
scientist in research and development at
thermo fisher scientific
and today we'll be discussing new
fixable viability dyes
and their applications to flow cytometry
now what is a fixable viability dye
specifically this is a fluorescent dye
that allows us to distinguish live cells
from dead cells in this case
a fixable viability dye is able to enter
through the compromised membrane of a
dead cell and bind to proteins
throughout the cell while a live cell
with an intact membrane excludes the dye
and so these cells have only dim
fluorescents
and so as we see on the bottom right
we'd expect cells to have a bright
positive peak and a dim negative peak
indicating the dead and live cells
and the the distribution of these peaks
is retained even after formaldehyde
fixation as opposed to those peaks on
the left
as seen with propitium iodide where the
distinction between live and dead cells
is lost after fixation
now most commonly this type of dye is
used
in combination with multi-color immuno
phenotyping
and so typically we try to choose a
colorifiability die
in a
panel designer tool
that will allow us to multiplex with the
maximum number of antibodies to answer
the questions
of our experiment
and the reason we we really need a
fixable viability dye in a multiplex
immunophenotyping experiment
is that gating on
live versus dead cells by scatter alone
is not sufficient they're actually dead
cells within this live cell scatter gate
and we can demonstrate that by further
gating
on a fixable
lived fixable violet
plot versus forward scatter where we can
see this this
uh theoretical live cell gate actually
has live and dead cells within it
now those dead cells um actually are
known to non-specifically bind
antibodies and can really dramatically
skew the results of our experiment
as we see if we look at only live cells
our distributions look as we'd expect
and so it is really critical
especially for
a high parameter experiments to include
a viability die
and so this week we're announcing the
launch of six new
uh fixable viability dyes
these range across the spectrum from the
violet all the way out to the near
infrared
and really fill under utilized channels
on a flow cytometer
so in every case
they have the same performance you're
used to where live and dead cells
are clearly distinguished even after
fixation
and now with a total of 14 colors
you have even greater choice when
designing a panel
and these panels
can be bigger now that
we have
additional reagents for example in the
very
far red
range of the spectrum
and so in the context of the existing
fixable viability dies here's the list
of all 14
with the six new
reagents highlighted in bold
and so you can see really for any
channel on a flow cytometer
there's a
probably a fixable viability die that
can be used or that can be added to
a multi-color
immunophenotyping experiment that you're
conducting
and as we can see regardless of the
color the distinction between live in uh
cells in the dim peak and dead cells in
the bright peak uh is similar we just
have the opportunity now to
install this viability indicator
in
whatever part of the spectrum
best suits your experiment
and so as part of this launch of six new
dyes
we have
gone back and looked at the workflow
looked at the protocol required
for these reagents
and so i'll show you
briefly some of some of the expanded
characterization we've done
to really study these dyes now first
the the protocol that exists with the
current live dead fixable dies includes
a low throughput
protocol
and realizing that
that today many researchers are not just
using a few tubes but are actually doing
medium throughput or
very high throughput experiments
we've expanded the the protocol included
with these kits to include
both of these methods now these are
similar in the fact that
the first step is dissolving the
dry dye in dmso
and then essentially making a one to one
thousand dilution onto cells
uh then carrying out an incubation step
um and then after that um i'll show you
dave's just to support this
but everything beyond this is um we can
consider optional and so it is
recommended to do
a wash step after labeling your cells
then it's possible to label
with antibodies against surface antigens
then fix and perm if you prefer
and then label with antibodies against
intracellular targets followed by
analysis but again everything in this
box is
is now optional for these
six new dies
on the medium throughput method
essentially we do the same thing we
dissolve our dye in dmso
and then depending on the number of
tubes that you need to label
just dilute this die one to one thousand
into pbs
spin down your cells and bring them back
up in one milliliter of this
ready-to-use working dye solution per
tube
so this helps you scale a bit more
quickly
for 96 or 384 well plates
essentially just spin down the plate and
remove the media from your cells and add
the working solution of dye to every
well and proceed with the rest of the
protocol
so these these reunions can all very
easily be applied to higher throughput
experiments
now i mentioned in the previous
slide
that
among the things that are optional
one of these is washing
and this this is somewhat surprising but
the data does does support this
conclusion that whether we wash
ourselves or we don't
whether we just label the cells and
immediately analyze them without washing
away unbound dye
we're still quite easily able to resolve
live and dead cells and in some cases as
in this near ir 876 example there's
really no difference between washed or
unwashed cells
for absolute best results it is still
recommended to wash but
in cases where your cells may be
sensitive
to you know centrifugation for example
it's it's not critical to
wash your cells
another interesting uh conclusion from
our additional characterization
experiments
is that
you do do you need to label your cells
in pbs alone or can you label cells with
some protein present such as
bovine serum albumin
and we can say
uh once again somewhat surprisingly that
we can label ourselves in
a buffer such as phosphate buffered
saline with one percent
bsa
and once again in in some cases there
may be a slight change in
the the signal or the background or both
but in in most cases there's very little
change
due to labeling in one percent bsa
and so in many cases this will save
you know a centrifugation step during
your workflow if your cells are already
in a fax buffer such as pbs with bsa you
can just go ahead and label them and
carry on with the protocol without a
buffer change
and
in the case of um you know complete
media such as 10 bsa i would recommend
using
either the near ir 780 or the lime 506
these both seem to be compatible with
protein concentration up to 10
uh with the other dyes we will expect
some some loss of signal with that much
protein present
but one percent is is compatible with
all six of these dyes
so another another
question that i often get from from
scientists is
if i label my cells now and fix and perm
them do i have to analyze them
immediately or is it okay to save them
and analyze them tomorrow or
you know on monday after after the
weekend
and so in in this experiment
i
labeled cells with four different dies
fixed and firmed them with the
ebioscience ic fix and perm kit and
analyze them and then put those samples
in the refrigerator in this case for 35
days
and analyze the same samples again
and so as you can see that distinction
between live and dead cells is very well
preserved because these dyes covalently
bind to proteins
within or on the surface of cells
and that
is essentially
largely unchanged over the course of a
month and so
i'd say
if you want to wait until tomorrow when
your
flow cytometer is available or if it's
friday afternoon and you want to wait
till monday
to analyze
the fixable viability dies are fine with
that
you might want to confirm
with the rest of your antibody panel if
it's
compatible with that but there's no
concern about losing
a distinction between life and dead
cells over time
now
another
potential
source of concern is are these dyes that
i'm putting on my cells going to be
toxic
in themselves that is
will these have some impact on the
viability of my cells just by labeling
them and so to to answer this
using the six
new dyes that we're introducing
i labeled a population of cells with
each of those and then put them back in
an incubator for 24 hours
and compared them to just dmso alone
and then using another class of
viability dyes called cytox dyes either
cytox red or cytotox blue
depending on the color requirements
we can see in every case our
cells have the same background
level of cell death which is about five
percent so there's really no change
between those cells labeled with dmso
alone for 24 hours or or
with dmso alone washed and then
incubated for 24 hours or those labeled
with any of these dyes and so we can say
that
these dyes are not
going to reduce more
cell death in our cells of interest
now a final
workflow example when you're
wanting to create single color controls
for your multi-color immuno phenotype
experiments
um each of these dyes is compatible with
our arc amine reactive compensation
beads
and with this um
this
bead product essentially we put one drop
of beads into a
cytometry tube and label it
with
whichever color of dye we'd like a
single color control for
after washing we had a negative bead and
we have two peaks that can be used to
very easily set compensation
for
these dyes without requiring uh the use
of of your cells um and so um
as i as i mentioned at the beginning
um these
new dies that we're introducing are
designed to fill channels where live
dead fixable dies did not exist
previously
and also they're
screened so that they have minimal
spillover into adjacent
channels on a flow cytometer and so for
example
using just the yellow laser on an
attuned nxt
flow cytometer
we can use the live dead fixable orange
in our
yl1 channel to get on live cells in this
case these are human pbmcs so we'll get
on live cells and get on lymphocytes
and then we can use
two additional markers sorry three
additional antibodies um
which are all pe tandems uh to
conduct a multicolored amino phenotyping
experiment
and as we can see
there is compensation required of course
but once applied we can readily
distinguish
positive and negative populations of
cells
and so in this case with four dyes all
on the same laser
we have now left the rest of our entire
flow cytometer available for
additional
markers
so
um a few uh highlights we discussed uh
and actually one that we didn't discuss
is we'd recommend labeling with these
dies for 20 minutes
to get the brightest signal
but in fact in in all cases two minutes
is often sufficient to get clear
distinction between
uh live and dead cells
so if your cells are very sensitive um
to being in the labeling environment
this is often sufficient but we would
recommend
for the best signal to continue for the
full 20 minutes
you can fix in perm but it's not
required
we also recommend washing after labeling
but again that's not required either
so if you
do want to sort your cells
this can be conducted as one of the last
steps before that
sorting
so let's move on now and we'll discuss
some applications
areas or experiments where
the addition of these dyes
brings to bring some value to you
now often
with a fixable viability die
you may not see just a positive and a
negative peak especially if you're using
blood cells
as in life's whole blood
or peripheral blood mononuclear cells
and in some cases we may see three peaks
so to help decide which peak we should
gate on
we can set a gate on the different
populations and then
back gate onto our scatter plot and see
where these are
in this case our dimmest peak is our
lymphocytes
this intermediate peak is in fact our
live monocytes while these two brighter
peaks are the live and dead lymphocytes
and so if we're interested in
uh immunophytic immunophenotyping all of
our cells we would probably expand this
gate to
include both of the populations on the
left
if we're interested just in lymphocytes
maybe
the gate on the left is is sufficient
but in fact a back gate will help answer
which which peak should you gate on
now another
tool that will help answer this question
is a new flow cytometer called the
attune
sight pix cytometer
now this is the same
a tuned nxt flow cytometer with the
added benefit of bright field images of
every cell
that you have acquired
and so we can now
set a gate on what we think is our live
cells
look at a scatter plot and see that
in fact these cells are
where we would expect live cells to be
by scatter
we now look at
three representative images of cells
within this gate we see they're round
and uniform and smooth
uh and and
as live cells should be
we now gain on the very bright positive
peak and back gate to our scatter plot
these are where we'd expect dead cells
to be
and we can see why the side scatter of
this population is higher they're quite
granular they have
some irregularity and some texture
inside
and so this is what our dead cells look
like
now in this experiment there was a third
peak in our viability histogram
if we get here and back gate we see
these are dead cells but also
what might be called you know beyond
dead these are starting to lose their
structural integrity and fall apart in
that case components of the cell that
have been labeled with our viability dye
are being lost and so
on a fluorescent
basis we'd expect these cells to be
dimmer and that's why this population is
less bright than the rest of the dead
cells
and so this is really why we see three
peaks in this example
now
the attuned sight picks instrument can
also be used to show
the the interesting morphology
of yeast cells
as determined uh to be live or dead
with live dead fixable orange viability
stain so if we get on our negative peak
which is our
live yeast cells we see that these are
in general a uniform circular shape but
in in some cases we see buds emerging
from the cells and this indicates that
these cells are live and actively
proliferating
and via budding they're creating new
yeast
those cells in the positive peak we know
are dead and with the bright field
images provided by the sitefix
instrument we can see there's really
irregular morphology here
that creates higher side scatter and in
fact we can confirm
not only that these are our singlets but
that they are
morphologically they look dead
so um
we can also look at other examples
for example in
immunotherapy
if we're studying chimeric antigen
receptor t cells uh very often these
cells after being produced are
cryopreserved
for shipment or storage
and upon thawing
we'd expect to see
a fair amount of dead cells within
our entire cell population
and so by scatter we can see this has
two populations which
we could say are roughly live and dead
by scatter
but as i demonstrated previously a
scattergate really isn't conclusive
we need the distinction between live and
dead cells
as indicated by a viability dye
and so here we have some car t cells
labeled with each of these six dies and
showing us a clear distinction between
those live and
dead cells
and so
we can use that distinction between live
and dead on an instrument such as the
in vitrogen bigfoot spectral cell sorter
to show us a couple of things one
we can visualize the entire
spectral emission profile of this dye
on a seven laser
bigfoot
cell sorter
but if we limit our
view to just one
fluorescent histogram of a single
channel in this case i'm excited at 561
with emission at 575 we can now gate on
live and dead cells
and actually go a step further and sort
out those live cells and
remove the dead cells from our car t
population
so in this example especially it can be
quite valuable to
remove
the dead cells from our entire
population of car t cells and only carry
on with our uh research or our analysis
on live car t cells
so if we can uh look within our entire
emission spectrum
uh to one specific channel and display
that a different way as a histogram
we can now sort out
the cells in the negative peak
and see that these are the live car t
cells well our dead cells in this case
we captured them but we can
just remove our dead cells from the
mixed culture
so
if if analysis is sufficient
each of these six new dyes is also
compatible with
other
full-spectrum cytometry instruments so
we can have a clear distinction between
live and dead cells
using whatever
spectral analysis instrument
is available to us
and while these dyes are intended for
flow cytometry uh of course they are
they provide very bright dead cells and
very dim
fluorescents in live cells uh this
distinction is also visible by using
fluorescence microscopy
and so for example using the evo m5000
imaging system we can swap out the
color of
the
led light cubes within this instrument
to match the
spectral requirements of any of these
dyes
and so we can see
with three different examples that our
dead cells are very brightly fluorescent
throughout the cell
while our live cells
have an absence of fluorescence
and so this this distinction is actually
visible
with fluorescence microscopy as well i
will give the caveat that these are
optimized for flow cytometry and so with
with microscopy
a couple of these dyes may have
photostability issues
and
with the very long stoke shift of some
of the live dead fixable dies it can be
challenging
to find a microscope that is compatible
with
the unusual
spectra of these dyes but the led light
cubes
contained within the evos imaging system
can also be adapted
to the countess 3fl automated cell
counter and so with this instrument we
can take 10 microliters of our cell
sample put it into a slide and
ask this instrument to give us not only
the concentration of our cells but
actually the percent
dead in this case so in this sample we
took
10 microliters of our car t cells
um
labeled with our lifetime fixable lime
506 viability die
and asked the countess
to give us the percent viable in this
case we have 60 dead cells and our cell
concentration
is 7 times 10 to the fifth per ml and we
actually have an image
where it it shows us which cells it's
counting is live and which are being
counted as dead
so
i want to thank everyone for
joining us today
i hope these new reagents will bring
value to
your flow cytometry experiments and
hopefully give you some new ideas uh for
what's possible
not only from a reagent perspective but
also uh with some of the really amazing
new flow cytometry instruments that are
available so thank you for your time
thank you for your time
and thank you chris for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of this webinar and if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and we'll answer as many
as we have time for
so
chris our first questions coming already
in from our great audience is
i would like to add a live dead fixable
viability
die to my spectral flow panel
can you provide any more guidance on how
to design this panel
yeah definitely thanks for the the
question
um and this is a key
uh concern now that we're seeing a lot
of research pivot from conventional
cytometry into spectral space
and more specifically wondering how
these dyes can be optimized to to
perform on a spectral
cytometer so first i just want to
mention that
we have some great guidance available on
our
website on thermofisher.com there's a
full
spectral cytometry page
with guidance about designing panels for
spectral cytometry
um
and also with our
spectroviewer the the excitation and
emission spectra of all of these dyes
are available
from 300 out to 900 nanometers so you
can really get a good idea of
where
some of these die show up in different
channels
and also just to just to mention
um as we developed each of these live
dead fixable
viability dyes
we
package them at a concentration where
you get the the best discrimination
between live and dead cells that is
they're at their brightest concentration
and so for conventional cytometry bright
is good
for spectral flow
uh bright brightest isn't always good
sometimes having a unique and narrow
spectrum is the best
and so to have good results on a
spectral cytometer for example i showed
on on the bigfoot or the aurora
you may need to tighter these dies down
as use a lower concentration because we
tend not to adjust the voltage
on each channel on a spectral instrument
instead we'd prefer to use a lower
concentration of these dyes
to bring
both the live and the dead peak onto
scale without having to change the
voltage
so that's one
one key piece of guidance is just
consider
once you decide on a color of dye to use
uh try doing a titration you know take
it down
in half or maybe you know one one
quarter of the die
to begin with just to ensure that your
dead cells are fully on scale and can be
unmixed from
your other fluorophores
so yeah thank you for the question
and thank you chris what about
fluorescent spill over in other channels
in absence of a washing step for these
new dyes
yes uh thanks for that also
and you know i um
just will reiterate that
um it it's surprising that we don't have
to wash ourselves after labeling with
these dyes and our standard protocol
still does say to
label yourselves first with a live dead
fixable viability die and then wash
and then proceed to your antibody
labeling and fixation steps um but when
your cell model requires it
it's possible not to wash
and so
in that case
um the
um the spillover to adjacent channels
should remain largely unchanged you know
in the different histograms that i
showed
in some cases we see a slightly higher
signal in our live cells
from not washing but usually our dead
cells are fully saturated to begin with
with dye and so we'd expect their
brightness to be largely unchanged
and also
the majority of users of these dyes are
going to be gating on their live cells
and then
continuing on to gate on their
various antibody markers in their panel
and live cells
we know are dim and so have very minimal
spillover into adjacent channels so with
these dyes we're not so much concerned
about
uh the spillover of these dyes into
to other channels but i also see a
a good follow-up question to this that
has has just shown up and actually how
we can compensate these
sure you did you want to go ahead and
and answer that question the question is
from our audience
how to accomplish how do we compensate
of those live dead die
yeah um
thank you susie and i think um
there are a couple of ways to compensate
these live dead dies and you know
compensation becomes critical as we get
into these larger panels with many
markers in many colors so i showed one
way to set compensation and that's using
our arc
amine reactive compensation beads that
are designed
to be labeled with amine reactive dye
such as these
and then just run as a single color
control so we can use compensation beads
for our antibodies and we can use
similar compensation beads
for our
viability dyes
however as we begin to look at
spectral cytometry
sometimes
beads are not preferred sometimes they
are
if if you prefer not to use beads to set
compensation for for any reason
it's also possible to take a sample of
your cells and kill them i generally
just use
50 or 60 degrees celsius
uh for 10 to 20 minutes depending on how
sturdy your cells are
so that you can get a nice population of
dead cells uh then we'll just label
those with the viability dye and that
will give us a nice bright uh population
to get on
and this is often a preferred method for
spectral cytometry so that we can have
our cells be consistent across all of
our
controls
so yeah i think thanks for the question
and thank you chris and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
we have a couple more our next audience
member says could you put up the slide
back up with the new dies um excitation
details and i know that we can't put our
slides up right now and i want to remind
our audience that all of the slides will
be on demand
following our presentation but chris did
you want to talk a little bit about that
slide maybe
um
provide some information for that
audience member
yeah um definitely so in in regards to
the the um you know now that there are
14 different dies
there are a lot of details as far as
excitation and emission
and where these fit into your instrument
and so we've we've built these details
into a web page
with all of
not only the excitation and emission but
three different kit sizes there's a
sample kit a medium and a very large
scale
kit for each of these
and the easiest way to find these
is just to go to thermofisher.com
live dead and live dead is all one word
and that will take you to all of
um the information that i showed
uh on these dies as well as um a lot of
other details
on you know how they're
how to use them a good protocol
for their use so thermofisher.com
live dead
or you can just google
wipe did fixable viability dies and it
will take you there as well
so hopefully that
clarifies
you know provides a good resource for
you to find more information on those
that's wonderful thank you so much we
have one more question
are live dead fixable viability dies
compatible with the nova floor antibody
conjugates
yeah good question and um
so
as we begin to pursue much larger flow
cytometry panels the the nova floor dyes
and especially nova flora antibody
conjugates are beginning to give us a
way
to
really significantly increase our
multiplexing ability so these are
new dyes
that
are intended to
have a narrow emission spectrum and fit
in quite nicely
into
larger panels
however they are
dna based
scaffolds and so
other types of viability dyes especially
dna binding viability dyes
are are not recommended for these so
things like dappy or perpedium iodide or
cytox are really not recommended for use
in multiplexing
with nova floor antibody conjugates
and so in in contrast to those all of
the amine reactive live dead fixable
viability dyes work very nicely
with nova floor antibody conjugates
and so
i have a lot of experience in the lab
using
various colors of the live dead fixable
viability dies in combination with
panels using
the nova floor antibody conjugates
and they they make a good
match together when you're pursuing a
larger
either conventional or
especially spectral cytometry panels so
yeah thanks for for mentioning that
chris i want to thank you for your
presentation today and for
important research would you like to
provide any closing remarks before we go
sure yeah thank you susie and i think um
just to reiterate uh we had a great
audience today uh thank you for all of
the insightful questions
um and of course uh
we value the feedback and it's really
the the feedback in response to events
like this that help us
innovate the next round of
of uh new reagents and especially new
instruments
so i encourage everyone to
visit thermofisher.com
live dead and find more information
about these uh reagents and also
uh the the data that i demonstrated
today on some of
the new
assisted cytometry and spectral sorting
instruments is available on that webpage
also
for for further information you can also
reach out
to your local thermo fisher scientific
representative for guidance on
panel design using these reagents and
really how best to use them and access
them in your lab so i want to thank
everyone for
joining us today and we'll look forward
to seeing you in the future
and thank you again chris for your
presentation today i'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast and now i'd
like to announce our two winners of the
t-shirt contest miranda batista and fun
talk akarak funny your t-shirts will be
mailed to you
we would like to also invite you all to
the next webinar on november 2nd titled
floor 4 fundamentals for flow cytometry
you can register for this event through
the lab roots website before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
with those slides and labyrinths will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone stay
safe bye-bye